This video is made possible by brilliant.
You're going to learn more about brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to learn more about them right now,
we've got a brilliant at org forward slash.
Biographics.
You'll also find a link in the description below.
Jeremy Bentham was a man ahead of his time,
though not a philosopher.
He developed a utilitarian philosophy based on the doing of good to oneself and
to others.
He used it to proposed fundamental reforms to assist in that he saw as grossly
unjust is ideas of reverberated down through the ages do affect the worlds that
we live in today.
In the biographics video today,
we delve into the life and the teachings of Jeremy Bentham.
Jeremy Bentham was born on the 15th of February,
1748 and houndsditch London.
The Bentham's.
We're a family of wealth and income was derived from an extremely successful
pawnbroking enterprise from generations past his parents,
James Nalla spend their time and social and intellectual pursuits.
Young Bentham was a child prodigy with his extraordinary abilities becoming
evidence very early on by the age of three.
He was reading fluently on one occasion when he had just turned three,
he was walking in the woods with his parents and some other adults.
The became bored with the adult conversation and decided to return home as the
adults who are absorbed in their conversation.
They didn't notice his departure when they returned to him.
The adults found him sitting at a reading desk,
absorbed and reading a book on the history of England's Jeremy's classical
studies again of the age of four,
the monkey journals of his father.
There exists a piece of paper with the following eyes.
The line pasted herein was risen by my son,
Jeremy Bentham on the 4th of December,
1753 at the age of five years,
nine months and 19 days.
The lining question,
but it was a long phrase in Latin.
This document shows not only the amazing talents of the child,
but it's also the obvious prides that the father had in his son's intellectual
gifts.
In fact,
James was constantly bragging about the genius that lay within us by that age,
for Jeremy was learning both the Greek and the Latin languages.
James employed,
uh,
Clark.
And this man was given the duty of teaching young James to write as well as to
read music and play the violin.
By the age of six,
a regular music tutor had been employed and James with his miniature fiddle
became an adaptive violinist.
James wanted for his son to excel at everything.
When Jeremy was seven he was given dancing lessons and it was something that he
absolutely detested.
The boy was so weak that he wasn't able to support himself on his tip toes.
Yup.
His father repeatedly forced him to go through the exercises becoming more
exasperated with every failed attempt.
We're not absorbed in his studies with his father.
Jeremy loved nothing better than to spend time at the country estates of it's
two grandmothers at Browning Hill and barking.
He was a lover of nature and would spend hours exploring the flowers and the
trees on the family's grounds.
Why Young James was mentally superior to
his peers physically,
hey was anything but he was much shorter than other children of his age and was
extremely thin and weak.
When he was seven years of age,
he began attending Westminster School in London.
He immediately hated the experience.
It being a far contrast to the one on one instruction that had been receiving
all my senses.
Beth.
He later wrote Westminster was a wretched place for instruction.
I was the least boy in the school.
Then to the bigger boys,
took pleasure in pissing us one against another.
Bentham was entered into the upper second form due to his obvious advanced
intellects.
He seemed to reputation is that digital philosopher as a result of his ability
to reason and consider every matter.
His skills in Latin and Greek made him a valuable boys and no ones,
any of the other boys leaned on him to provide homework answers soon became a
target for bullies at the school.
However,
there was one boy who was just a protector for him.
If it wasn't for this companionship,
he would have been the subject of daily humiliations and his older years.
He spoke with disgust fagging system by which younger boys were subjected to all
manner of intolerant treatment.
He was just as dismissive of the teaching that was offered at the school,
saying that he was taught a few useful and many useless things.
Bentham observed that the higher the rank of the professor,
the less efficient the man was.
Bentham persevered with the agony and is boredom of Westminster for five years.
Finally,
the age of 12 he graduated and just father enrolled him at Queens College in
Oxford.
It was a remarkable achievement for such a young man to be enrolled in
university.
The fact that Bentham was extremely short for a 12 year old me didn't and even
greater curiosity than usual,
and he was standouts wherever he went.
In addition to developing an extraordinary intellectual body of knowledge,
by the time he was a teenager,
Bentham had also built for himself a strong moral code.
He recalls,
I never told a lie.
I never in my remembrance,
did what I knew to be a dishonest thing.
His father placed him under the care of a personal tutor by the name of Jacob
Jefferson.
He was a morose and gloomy past and you saw it as his duty to prevent Jeremy
from having anything that even remotely resembled fun.
The only thing that run basically approached one in Jeremy's life was to play at
shuttlecock very irregularly.
Yes.
Even this was unacceptable to Jefferson and d would interrupted the game and
Ashton the boy back to his books.
He instilled in Bentham's psyche that any activity that did not involve
educational advancement was a waste of time.
While at Oxford Bentham,
Oni received a modest allowance from his father.
This meant that he was forced to incur debt.
His father was also concerned that the boy was too timid and too shy.
On one occasion while visiting Oxford,
James took his sons the grand total at Christ church.
At the time,
the students there were all the sampling for dinner.
James instructed to sun to walk up and down the aisles and see if he could find
any of the boys that he knew.
For Jeremy.
This was a hellish assignments.
With each succeeding step,
he fell place it to fainting.
By the time he had finished,
he was red with embarrassment and it's had no acquaintances to report his father
though thought this was an excellent strategy for his son to get noticed further
to goal.
He bought a silk,
a gown for journey while the other boys were playing gallons.
Bentham found the instruction doc so it almost is pointless and uninspiring as
he found the instruction at Westminster.
He managed at times to escape the monotony of his routine with fishing which she
was not particularly fond of.
He founds no pleasure in the company you have any other students considering the
vast majority of them to be in a chair.
Morons when he was 16 and Jeremy's father took him on a tour of France.
He was fascinated by the beauty and the architecture of Paris being especially
impressed by the one does have the palace of Versailles.
Surely.
Thereafter,
his father remarried January step.
Mother,
former Mrs Abbott's had a strange relationship with Bentham and he also spoke
with her with the lack of affection.
In 1766 Ben took his master's degree at Oxford with a major in law to celebrate
his graduation.
His father gave him the gift of 20 pounds.
The following.
Yeah,
he left Oxford in his own estimation.
Is Education at the college had not benefits stim Jane's had intended the Jeremy
would use the opportunities that the college do.
You establish contacts that he would be able to exploit upon graduation in order
to make his way up in the wells,
but the boy had been unable to shake his natural timidity and he didn't build
any meaningful relationships with people who are going to help him in the
future.
Bentham was admitted to the bar in 1769 though he never ended up practicing law.
He became greatly disappointed with the English legal code,
which she considered it to be overly cumbersome and rather complex.
His disillusionments was compounded upon after hearing a series of lectures by
the leading legal authority of the time Sir William Blackstone.
After listening to Blackstone,
he decided that he no longer wanted to practice law.
Instead Z,
it was going to write about it.
He would spend his energy is critiquing the existing door and proposing ways
that it could be improved and then took another tour of France with his father
and stepmother and the latter half of 1769 in 1717 Bentham stops it upon his
extensive writing career.
His first published work,
sweat,
two letters sent to the London Gazeta when he was 23 one of these letters,
he later said it was a portrait of my character and my love of Fatness,
Lord Mansfield had been attacked.
I showed that there was no evidence for the story.
Bentham spends an inordinate amount of time perfecting every words that he
committed it to.
Paper.
Everything had to be precise is that the writing's often contain the seeds of
the ideas that were fully flashed out and his more famous later works.
In July of 1776 the American colonies issued that declaration of independence.
The British government did not lower themselves to issue an official response.
However,
a London based pamphleteer was commissions to publish a rebuttal.
The man who was charged with writing this piece a lot of course was Jeremy
Bentham.
However,
the response was not published under Bentham's name.
That was rather the final chapter of John Lynn's onset to the declaration of
independence.
Bentham was a good friend of Len's was living at his house.
When Lynn's was commissioned to the job.
He was delighted to take on the Americans in print.
You proceeded to pull apart the declaration ruthlessly exposing its points.
He sets the tone in his introduction declaring the opinions of the modern
Americans on governments like those of their good ancestors on witchcraft would
be too ridiculous to deserve any notice if like them to contemptible and
extravagant as they be.
They had an auto lead to the most serious evils among as many critiques.
Bentham ridiculed the idea of all men being created equal,
stating that it gives equal status to the newborn baby and the magistrate.
He also claims that the use of the government to ensure the attainments of life,
liberty,
and pursuit of happiness is an oxymoron as the exercise of any form of
government well alienated,
at least one of those inalienable rights.
Bentham dismisses the framers of the Declaration of independence is nothing more
than a mob of radicals worse even than the German Anabaptists.
He concludes with sincere wishes that these ungrateful and rebellious people be
forced back into line.
I think now is the perfect time to tell you about today's sponsor brilliance.
These long videos,
they are made possible because of sponsors like brilliant,
so it would mean a lot to me if you took a moment when you're finished with this
video to go and check them out.
You're doing that really does allow us to keep doing what we do here at
biographics and bringing you these longer videos.
So Brilliance Ra science learning platform that allow you to learn through
active learning,
which summed up is basically the opposite of that feeling of reading through
some really complex page about some principal and just having no idea what's
going on because you've never put it into practice.
Brilliant cover everything from the very basics,
do the very complex,
but they make it all very,
very manageable.
Now you've heard me talk a bunch about brilliance.
If you are a regular viewer and it's a perfect fit for this channel because hey,
if you're watching a 20 minute video on youtube that's educational,
you're probably like learning,
so you're probably going to be into brilliant as well.
Reasonably Brilliance.
I've made an important update to their mobile app so that courses can now be
accessed offline so you don't have to worry about having a solid internet
connection to learn things through their platform.
Also,
they've got something called daily challenges,
which is where every day you have a problem to solve as a great way to spend
maybe five minutes saying like I say it on your commute and getting to grips
with a subject.
So like I say,
brilliant makes even complex concepts,
easy to understand.
So they give you something super short to read,
it's very easy to grasp and then you immediately applied to a problem or rinse
and repeat and suddenly,
or understanding very complex stuff that you didn't think you would be.
All courses are totally interactive,
so you can understand probability by playing blackjack of those sorts of things.
So if you want to support biographics that would be awesome and get access to
all of brilliance in depth maths and science courses.
Head over to brilliant.org forward slash by graphics to get 20% off the annual
premium subscription and let's get back to Bentham because we're about to get
into his most famous ideas and all the weird thing that happened after he died.
Having dismissed the American's Bentham set is focus on writing about social and
legal reforms in his beloved England's,
one of his pet projects was a design for an improved prison called the
panopticon,
the design of the structure and now every prisoner in the facility to be able to
be watched by a single God without them knowing whether or not they were under
observation.
Bentham was well aware that there was a new way that a single watchmen can
actually keep an eye on everyone at the same time,
but the fact that prisoners didn't know if they were being watched words
according to Bentham forced them to regulate their own behavior.
The panel.
What's gone was a second a building with a watch house in the center where a God
could monitor all of the inmates.
Bentham describe the design as a mill for grinding rogues.
Honest,
in 1791 Bentham published a book on his pan optic on plants.
He fully intended for the prison to be built and even plans to govern the
facility himself.
In 1794 he was able to interest the government of William pet in the idea he was
paid 2000 pounds for his plans.
After a number of frustrating holdups Bentham ended up buying a plot of lands on
behalf of the crowd and 1799 from his perspective,
the site was far from ideal when he requested more funds to go and buy lands.
He was told to simply build a smaller prison from this.
He discerned that there was no real commitment to penal reform on the parts of
the governments.
When William Pitt resigned from parliament in 1801 enthusiasm for the project
waned two years later,
it was shut down completely Benson.
He was crushed by the closing down of his pet project stating they have murdered
my best days.
Bentham's political philosophy is summed up in the concept of utilitarianism.
It is based on the principle that an action is right only if it promotes
happiness and wrong if it does not promote happiness.
That happiness relates not only to the instigator of an action but to the rest
of society as well.
Bentham's answer to the question,
what should a person do is that a person should do only that which produces the
best consequences.
Benson,
he was not a professional philosopher as a critic and shaper of the law.
He believed that his utilitarian principal should be the practical guide by
which all people,
including the law makers in governments,
make decisions.
There's underlying principle was summed up by his contemporary Joseph Priestley
as the greatest happiness for the greatest number.
His greatest wish was that the more makers of society would use this principle
in order to remake a more equitable and logical legal framework for society.
He wrote.
If anything could be identified as the fundamental motivation behind the
developments of classical utilitarianism,
it would be the desire to see useless cropped laws and social practices changed
in determining what was good and what was bad.
Bentham believed that the pursuit of pleasure and the avoidance of pain with the
deciding factors,
he held it as a given that pleasure.
It was good and that pain was bad.
The fact that a person is rich or poor,
black or white.
Now female intelligence or dimwitted should,
he believes I have absolutely no bearing on their right to enjoy the same level
of pleasure and avoid the same measure of pain as anyone else in the class
defined society that was England at the time.
This was a pretty radical notion.
Benson was never interested in anything unless it could be practically applied
in society.
In order to help people to apply his utilitarian theory,
he developed what he called the hedonic calculus.
By using it,
people would be able to balance out the pleasurable and painful effects of any
proposed action they had on in calculus include seven factors which need to be
taken into account in relation to the pleasure or pain produced when considering
a course of action.
The intensity duration set and the remoteness extends piracy.
And if that come today or likelihood that the sensation will be followed by more
of the same.
And example of the committee that Bentham gave was smiling at a stranger.
This may make you feel good for a short period of time.
This am,
I also calls that stranger to smile at someone else and this could keep going
indefinitely.
So the sensation would be repeated many times over.
Purity is the opposite.
If a committee,
we might get a temporary feeling of pleasure by punching someone in the face,
but the chances are high that they will punch us right back,
in which case we will get to the opposite sensation.
So the sensation is not pure,
it's quickly diluted,
so to speak.
And the 1790 [inaudible] became interested in helping clean up a notorious area
known as the pool of London.
This was a stretch that ran along the river Thames from London bridge down to
line house.
It was the center of crime vice and all sorts of illegal activity and major
problem was shipboard theft with merchants losing half a million pounds of
merchandise.
Every year of them worked with a Scottish magistrate by the name of Patrick Hoon
for a solution to the problem.
What they cannot with was the Thames River Bill,
which was passed into law in the air racing hundreds they brought into existence
the Thames River police.
This force,
the first police force in England was specifically designed to stop theft and
looting from ships.
It was designed to act as a preventative for crime,
which was sort of a new concept at the time
by the 17 ATS Bentham's writings and influence.
It made him an influential weld thinker.
He was in contact with many people of note the Cavs Harper lively communication
with Scottish economist Adam Smith in an attempt to bring about free floating
interest rates or so was in communication with the movers and shakers of the
French revolution.
However,
when things devolved into the mass terror of wholesale,
the headings,
he rounds and he criticized what was happening there.
Bentham is remembered as one of the earliest advocates of animal rights
extending his utilitarian philosophy.
He stated that it was not the ability to reason,
but rather the ability to feel which determines who or what was covered by the
pleasure and pain principle.
Bentham did believe that animals could be killed for food or if a person was
defending themselves or others from attack,
but only so long as there was no gratuitous suffering involved.
Bentham was also well ahead of his time when it came to the issue of women's
rights.
In fact,
he once stated this,
it was the inequality in the treatment of women that he observed in his youth.
That first prompted him to take the role of lifelong reformer,
even though he was of the belief that women were both physically and
intellectually weaker than men.
His utilitarian philosophy prescribes that they should be able to enjoy equal
rights.
How's he approached his eighties Benson began to give serious consideration to
his death and his legacy.
He rose detailed directions regarding what was to be done with his corpse.
In 1830 he wrote a paper in which he instructed the English physician,
Tom Southwood Smith to create what he called an auto icon and this was attached
to his will.
Jeremy Bentham died on June the sixth 1832 at his home in Westminster in London.
According to his instructions,
his body was dissected in the presence of his friends.
The auto icon was created by reconstructing the skeleton,
replacing the head with a wax model,
and then dressing it up in his clothes and placing it on a seat and the glass
case.
This energy along with the mummified head of Bentham,
Ms Still on display at university college in London.
So ready.
Hope you found that video.
Interesting.
Particularly that last bit.
I did.
Rather like,
if you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos several times a week.
If you're looking for more from me,
why no checking my other channel called top tens you'll find that linked to two
below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.